pour être très honnête je commence à
avoir des petites
dans ce cas là on va monter de Salim
tout petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauvé secourir protéger
finalement j'ai changé de cap je suis
journaliste et j'ai décidé d'aller à la
rencontre de ces hommes et de ses femmes
qui exercent des métiers hors du commun
aujourd'hui je suis avec la Patrouille
de France la première fois je fais ça de
ma vie ils sont neufs l'élite de l'élite
tous pilotes de chasse
issus des unités de combat de l'armée de
l'air
on est certes soldat au départ et
soldats dans l'âme mais la Patrouille de
France c'est un autre combat leur
nouvelle mission
représenter la France dans le monde
entier et toucher le grand public
l'admiration un exercice qui demande des
heures et des heures d'entraînement et
qui n'est pas sans danger ces pilotes
évoluent à plus de 800 km/h à 3 mètres
les uns des autres
je vais en trouver la porte de ce club
d'élite et même voler avec eux
[Musique]
mais avant de tutoyer les nuages il me
faut remplir une petite formalité dans
la grisaille parisienne
[Musique]
on peut surpage tout commence par une
visite médicale figurez-vous puisque si
tout va bien je dois voler avec la
Patrouille de France on monter dans
l'avion et comme je crois que c'est une
épreuve quand même assez physique on
vérifie que je suis en état de santé de
le faire et donc j'ai rendez-vous avec
un médecin de l'armée de l'armée de
l'air qui va vérifier ma capacité à
affronter cette épreuve
j'ai rendez-vous dans le service du
médecin chef Martel un service
spécialisé dans l'évaluation du
personnel navigant de l'armée de l'air
[Musique]
il faut bien vous coller contre le mur
de droite donc là c'est les mesures pour
être sûr pour entrer dans un siège et
que vous pouvez bien éjecter vous avez
la longueur maximum des fémur la
longueur minimum la hauteur maximale à
hauteur mini et vous avez la même chose
pour la tête et je vais également vous
mesurer le bras
[Musique]
de l'éjection de que vos jambes se
retrouvent coincées dans dans l'appareil
et d'avoir une mauvaise éjection
les tibia voilà c'est parfait pour
l'instant je rentre dans le siège
électable
mon dossier et je vous laisse continuer
pour la suite bonne journée la suite des
examens vise à déterminer mon état de
santé général oreille droite
en apparence ces contrôles ont l'air
tout à fait banal
ces examens permettent d'évaluer la
capacité de mon corps à résister aux
grandes pressions qu'il va subir au
cours du vol et surtout en cas
d'éjection
ça fera mieux le verdict le résultat
n'est donc pas acquis
en général alors à l'issue de cette
visite médicale bien menée donc vous
pouvez aller
vous vous mettre mettre dans un avion de
chasse de type Alpha Jet merci Docteur
je vous en prie j'espère que pour vous
ça restera un moment inoubliable je
l'espère j'y compte bien
la PAF la Patrouille de France est une
institution militaire elle est basée à
Salon-de-Provence tout près d'Aix sur la
base de l'école de l'air qui forment les
officiers de l'armée de mer à l'entrée
je tombe sur un mystère 4 l'un des
premiers avions des pionniers de la PAF
les 9 pilotes de la Patrouille de France
sont choisis chaque année parmi les
pilotes de chasse les plus aguerris
minimum 10 ans d'expérience il perpétue
depuis 60 ans un savoir-faire
exceptionnel bonjour on m'a positionné
au pied de l'escalier pour vous saluer
bonjour enchanté bonjour
l'équipe de la Patrouille de France
suite un programme millimétré merci de
m'accueillir parmi vous cette semaine
ah oui pour le sport jamais monsieur de
toute ma vie
mais ça fait plaisir de vous en faire du
sport
tous les matins c'est comme ça
sous la direction de leur coach ils
enchaînent les exercices individuels
moyenne d'âge 35 ans
la plupart ont fait la guerre sur rafale
ou sur Mirage au Tchad en Libye ou en
Afghanistan
[Musique]
2 1 top c'est parti
parmi eux deux commandants dont le
leader qui vont rester deux ans les 7
autres sont tous capitaines et seront
pilotes de la PAF pendant 3 ans
[Musique]
natif doloron près de Pau le capitaine
Benjamin Michel n'est là que depuis
quelques mois c'est sa première année et
il est encore en phase d'apprentissage
très spécifique et c'est pour ça qu'on
fait des exercices très spécifiques
aussi c'est surtout sur la sangle
abdominale tout ce qui maintient du dos
etc si on se prépare pas on
peut pas arriver à supporter par contre
on se prépare un petit peu il y a aucun
problème
ça marche bien
les deux séances de sport journalière ne
sont pas de trop pour entretenir des
organismes que chaque vol et il y en a
parfois trois par jour mais paru des
preuves donc là chaque heure par à sa
voiture c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
une minute après il n'y avait plus
personne
il est 8h25 ils ont pas traîné une
minute après ils vont où là
après la séance de sport il est temps de
préparer le premier vol de la journée
assisté à ce mystérieux protocole c'est
pénétrer dans le secret de la Patrouille
de France
comment vol c'est le leader le
commandant Jean-Michel Herpin qui dirige
ce qu'on appelle la musique la
répétition mentale de l'enchaînement des
figures du prochain spectacle
[Musique]
des dentelles un cap sur le seuil de
plan de Dieu on est embraya relaxant
chez de 5 ans
je diminue l'inclinaison pour une boucle
on y va boucle
très grand flèche au top
on essaie de se rapprocher au maximum du
vol pour pour beaucoup d'ailleurs c'est
ce mimétisme se fait les yeux fermés
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut
voir il y a une grande similitude avec
un skieur de descente qui mentalise sa
piste et qu'il a et qu'il a révise avant
de faire sa descente mais nous c'est
exactement pareil on visualise toute
notre trajectoire et ensuite bercer par
la rythmée je dirais par la musique du
leader on va mettre tous ces coups de
cadence et branchements de fumée les
couper à savoir et à ses ordres fumer
top en diamant top
je diminue l'inclinaison rend un coup de
trait les pilotes pendant la musique ont
des actions souvent avec le pouce c'est
la coordination qu'on fait au trim le
leader le fait et en fait on le fait
tous en même temps si vous regardez tous
les pilotes sur un ordre de cadence tout
le monde va prendre ce coup de cadence
au trim et dans cette semi-métisme
maximum du vol il y a aussi tous les
coups de fumée la fumée top on branche
la fumée les coups de palette avec un
autre doigt ou les actions au gaz ou à
la radio
[Musique]
et je débauche
voilà comme ça c'est fait
et bien on a une bonne dizaine de
minutes
immuable la musique a été pratiquée par
des générations de pilotes depuis la
création de la patrouille en 1953
l'actuel directeur de la PAF le
lieutenant-colonel Arnaud Ambert a été
leader il y a une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
donc on a devant le leader le numéro 1
Atos 1 atos est en indicatif de la
patrouille c'est le chef c'est lui qui
décide c'est le leader en vol c'est le
commandant de l'équipe au sol aussi
d'accord il est entouré par ce qu'on
appelle le box avant ces deux intérieurs
les deux les deux avions qui sont
directement collés à lui derrière lui le
charognard le numéro 4 qui sera en tout
cas qui est le futur leader qui sera
leader l'année d'après
un jour l'année d'après obligatoirement
dans notre fonctionnement depuis bien
des années
celui qui est amené à être leader et en
première année charognan d'accord
derrière quatre avions
qui sont qui constituent le box arrière
qui est le boxer est emmené par le
numéro 7 le leader solo suivi de son
numéro 8 le second solo qui lui l'année
d'après deviendra leader solo mais la
vedette là dedans c'est le numéro ce
leader ou pas non la vedette la danse
c'est la Patrouille de France
tradition oblige dans le couloir les
casques de ces messieurs sont installés
en formation
vous prenez vos casques comme d'autres
prennent les selles de leur chevaux
sont posés dans le coin
le capitaine Shanna est l'une des trois
nouvelles recrues de cette saison
c'est un métier passion donc c'est aussi
super content de partager au boulot moi
je dépose mon fils chez nous
le travail donc on exerce à 15
c'est justement ce qu'on essaie de
communiquer aux gens
de constater comme des métiers jugés
extraordinaires de l'extérieur
finalement les gens après ils ont leur
casque accroché un truc ils le prennent
et puis le mettre sur la tête
voilà c'est quand même ça appartient à
leur quotidien quoi pour toute la saison
chaque pilote a son propre avion et
chaque avion à son propre mécanicien
9h30 le décollage est imminent les
pilotes vont saluer leur mécano
la complicité est manifeste
dans l'armée de l'air la prudence
élémentaire veut qu'un pilote ne décolle
jamais sans avoir vérifié lui-même son
avion
mais pas à la Patrouille de France ici
le pilote fait entièrement confiance à
son mécanicien
le sergent-chef Philippe Colin est en
binôme avec le pilote de l'avion numéro
6 ouais le pilote il arrive il arrive il
monte l'avion
vous êtes ses yeux et vous prenez un
responsabilité parce que vous avez
[Musique]
quand même tous les avions et ça va au
delà parfois cette proximité entre le
pilote et le mécanicien c'est que vous
pouvez vous voir à l'extérieur vous êtes
allés dîner chez eux ils viennent dîner
chez vous c'est le truc
dans les hôtels pendant les quand même
d'accord
à partir de maintenant plus question de
déconcentrer les pilotes leurs esprits
ont déjà pris de l'altitude ils vont
voler pendant une heure à quelques
mètres les uns des autres et parfois à
100 mètres à peine du sol
ce qui est en fait c'est le fait qu'il
soit côte à côte c'est carré plusieurs
biens bon c'est un avion mais quand il y
a
le capitaine blancailleur
occupe la position d'extérieur droit
numéro 6
[Musique]
qu'on n'a pas forcément ailleurs il y a
toujours un mécano mais c'est vraiment
identifié ça c'est vraiment le même tout
au long de la saison vous aurez le même
exactement
c'est le mécanicien qui choisit son
pilote c'est une particularité
[Musique]
c'est un moment critique le mécanicien
va retirer les goupilles qui neutralise
le siège éjectable une fausse manœuvre
et le pilote peut se retrouver éjecté à
plusieurs centaines de mètres
[Applaudissements]
9h45 je vais pouvoir assister à une
démonstration de la Patrouille de France
les avions décolle systématiquement par
groupe de 4 et dès le départ la
synchronisation est parfaite
il se touche presque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après une heure à répéter les figures
retour au sol un an les avions
reprennent leur place au parking
invariablement garé dans l'ordre d'Atos
1 le leader jusqu'à atosuite la tension
retombe c'est le moment pour le mécano
Philippe Colin de débriefer le vol avec
son pilote moi je retourne voir le
capitaine grand ailleurs
[Musique]
ouais très bien c'est bien passé ouais
super on fait ça combien deux fois par
jour
[Musique]
combien de temps
et vous répétez des morceaux à chaque
fois de
chaud là donc là vous en êtes où au
début au milieu on fait là on est
si on assemble les deux morceaux qu'on
fait on aura quasiment fait le ruban
complet d'accord
le ruban c'est la partie à 8 avions
qui s'oppose à la synchronisation où là
les les avions se disent aussi
et surtout la semaine passée on a fait
on a on a mis les fumées donc ça ça
c'est assez difficile parce qu'il y a ça
prend un peu plus de cases on va dire
aux avions il a quel âge celui-là il est
arrivé en 80 dans les forces donc après
c'est un roulement sur toute la flotte
Alphajet pour que la patrouille il a 33
ans 34 moi ça m'impressionne je pensais
que c'était des avions les plus récents
possible au contraire des avions de
musées là
en réalité ces avions conçus à l'époque
par Dassault sont rénovés pièce par
pièce à la moindre usure ils sont
anciens et 9 en même temps
le sergent cher Collin a de quoi être
fier de son bébé
comme une voiture sur ce moteur là on a
une petite
jauge à huile sinon pour l'enfon c'est
on la ressortant on voit le niveau là
de bachage de l'avion la soute à bagages
quand on part en convoyage
nos petits sacs des vols
minimum pour partir
il faut dire qu'en période de meeting
cet avion fait aussi le taxi les pilotes
et leur mécano voyagent à bord de
meeting en meeting pendant les 5 mois
que dure la saison en France et à
l'étranger
à la fin de mon séjour en une seule
heure de vol j'aurai le temps de faire
un aller-retour entre la Méditerranée et
les Alpes je trouve ça fascinant la
fascination c'est justement le métier de
la Patrouille de France
promouvoir notre pays et l'Armée de
l'Air auprès du grand public d'ailleurs
ce matin ils sont une cinquantaine de
visiteurs venus assister à
l'entraînement
c'est l'occasion pour le capitaine kicho
chargé de la communication de la
patrouille de souligner la dimension
diplomatique de la PAF
la première grande tournée cette
présence de Gaulle en 5959 qui sollicite
l'emploi parce que la France pour
l'amener défiler en fait à Saint-Louis
du Sénégal
en 86 c'est la première grande tournée
en fait de la Patrouille de France qui
défile devant le président Reggane en
2004 c'est le président Chirac Jacques
Chirac qui emmène la Patrouille de
France en Chine et en 2009 plus proche
de nous c'est le président Sarkozy qui
l'emmène en fait défilé au Brésil donc
pour les intérêts qui sont liés à ceux
de la France intérêt bien sûr
aéronautique parfois industriel mais
pour bien pour emprunter en fait notre
pays et le savoir-faire et l'excellence
de du pays de la France voilà
je l'ai éprouvé moi-même on est
forcément admiratif des prouesses
techniques que seuls quelques pilotes au
monde sont capables d'accomplir
60 ans d'expérience 7 mois
d'entraînement par an à raison de 8h par
jour 1500 litres de kérosène à l'heure
de vol le prix de cette gigantesque
campagne publicitaire tricolore et
forcément élevé
mais le résultat est là ces as de
l'aviation incarnent une France qui fait
rêver et les gens en redemande
c'est sympa
et oui je sers de support aussi ce rêve
bleu blanc rouge à quelque chose de
magique lorsqu'il redescend à hauteur
d'homme
on peut le toucher
ça sert à dire diminuer les frais des g
de facteur de charge sur et surtout sur
le sur le sang qui hérite le cerveau ça
veut dire que le sang qui règle le
cerveau au lieu de descendre dans les
dans les membres inférieurs il va rester
en comprimant les membres inférieurs et
la ceinture abdominale il va rester un
peu plus longtemps dans le cerveau j'ai
dit un peu plus longtemps il va pas
rester agit jamais ça veut dire que si
on prend trop de facteurs de charge il
va finir par partir et là ça sera le
voile noir et ensuite la perte de
connaissance donc ça ça limite le niveau
auquel on va perdre connaissance
[Applaudissements]
mais tout le monde n'a pas la même chose
que moi je suis encore pour quelques
jours l'invité de la patrouille et
demain c'est le grand jour je vole sur
un avion de chasse le sergent romain
Pascal sera notre mécanicien il m'ouvre
les portes du hangar je vais pouvoir me
familiariser avec la bête
[Musique]
c'est la qu'on constate qu'on est
extrêmement souple
début sur le ciel et après vous glissez
le dedans
c'est pas mal ça c'est une phase de
chauffage que j'aime bien
chose importante pour vous
la vitesse donc exprimer en eux
l'horloge
et ici l'horizon fait d'accord et votre
position en fait par rapport à l'horizon
c'est à dire que normalement un moment
donné ça va faire un truc comme ça ça va
bouger OK
ici ça c'est l'altimètre c'est pour vous
indiquer à quelle hauteur vous êtes ok
aussi la personne qui se trouve ici peut
prendre les commandes
la gadget est un avion à la base et un
avion écoles et en place avant le
moniteur en place arrière ok donc le
moniteur a la même chose en fait à
l'arrière que à l'avant donc il a les
manettes des gaz le manche les
instruments de bord une navigation et
vous allez trouver le marche-pied et
tout juste ici
et voilà descendu mais c'est pas plus
difficile que de descendre à cheval
OK et ben voilà c'est c'est bien d'avoir
fait cette petite initiation parce qu'en
fait
c'est sécurisant
merci à demain alors je vous en prie à
demain
à demain en général les gens ils sont
comment quand ils descendent le sourire
jusqu'aux oreilles c'est vrai bon
[Musique]
mais il faudrait ne pas penser
la plus forte sur la poignée d'éjection
et on tire la poignée et les moteurs
physiques qui se trouvent sous le ciel
pour vous propulser hors de la
trajectoire de l'avion
pour être très honnête je commence à
avoir des petites
cas là on va monter de salive
8h du matin demain je serai là-haut dans
l'un de ses avions à plus de 700 km/h en
attendant je quitte la base avec une
équipe chargée de filmer les évolutions
de la patrouille depuis le sol
le capitaine Guy lui-même ancien pilote
de la PAF communiquera avec le leader
par radio
s'il n'y a pas de vidéo et bien il peut
pas y avoir de vol tout simplement pour
que l'on puisse en cas d'un événement
particulier avoir un retour d'expérience
visuelle voilà et tout est archivé de ce
fait là
ça vous oblige à chaque fois allez vous
poser sous le passage de la de la
patrouille et de la filmer quoi c'est ça
à l'issue du vol je vais leur ramener la
vidéo et avec eux on va débriefer le vol
ensemble et en ça nous permettra de
revenir sur des phases de vol bien
particulier tous les vols en vidéo oui
tous les vols en vidéo
l'entraînement a lieu à une heure de
route de Salon de Provence au-dessus
d'une piste désaffectée
mais pourquoi on change le fait de
changer quelque part de théâtre un peu
comme pour des acteurs ah ben ça valait
ça va les mettre dans un nouveau milieu
une nouvelle condition parce qu'on
pourrait dire que l'air s'élève oui tout
à fait l'air s'énerve mais
l'environnement non il joue vraiment
en phase d'entraînement cette zone
baptisée plan de Dieu est fermée à tout
autre navigation aérienne
l'installation du point central ne prend
que quelques minutes une radio va
permettre au capitaine Guy de
transmettre au leader des informations
vue du sol
on installe tout la caméra
est relié aussi en radio s'il fait qu'on
a aubryfing on aura une image des
évolutions
et aussi le son le son est important et
toutes des annonces radio sont vraiment
très importantes donc là ils partent
dedans normalement ils sont en train de
décoller de Salon-de-Provence ils sont
décollant dans 10 minutes
pile à l'heure la patrouille déchire le
ciel
uni comme les trois couleurs de drapeau
français
clic-clac ça c'est pour Twitter
[Musique]
c'est exactement la sensation que
j'avais au décollage hier c'est elle qui
sont mais là quoi ils sont là ils sont
là on a l'impression qu'ils sont à 20 cm
la moindre précision sur le manche la
moindre faute
et ça arrive pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà le leader qui parle annonce tout
ce qu'il fait je dégauchie circuit en
virage et qui va remettre les à plat
donc il annonce avant même de le faire
comme ça les pilotes qui sont assez gels
savent qu'il va négocier ils ont ici
toutes les actions aux commandes
c'est rigolo parce que
les mecs qui travaillent dans les vignes
ils regardent en fait ils sont arrêtés
de bosser ils ont la tête en l'air ils
sont plus du tout ensemble
1015 merci beaucoup et bien on quitte la
fréquence la prochaine au revoir
[Musique]
11 heures lors du casse-croûte qui
permet au pilote de reprendre des forces
car une heure de sport plus une heure de
vol ça creuse
jambon beurre
très équilibré
j'adore me faire servir le café par des
capitaines
et très vite un grand renfort de gestes
dont un seul connaisse la signification
les voilà qui parlent les repars de ce
qui est leur seul préoccupation durant
leur présence dans la patrouille le vol
les figures le spectacle
une vie que ce jeune commandant de
l'armée de l'air voudrait bien partager
aujourd'hui il vient postuler pour la
saison prochaine et en fait vous vous
venez parce que vous êtes déjà séduit ou
pour les séduire
c'est le jeu c'est le jeu des journées
de
sélectionner
19 19 personnes qui vont venir ils sont
venus déjà c'est 3 derniers à venir et
parmi les 19 personnes à être venues là
dans les deux dernières semaines il y en
a trois qui seront pris pour l'année
prochaine et c'est vous quiez choisirez
comme moi j'étais choisi l'année
dernière donc c'est pas une période
facile c'est c'est pas évident parce que
on a très envie mais en même temps ça
c'est pas de notre ressort c'est
vraiment du ressort de l'équipe qui va
choisir des gens qui vont venir donc
c'est c'est pas évident c'est une
période pas facile et en plus vous les
choisissez pas sur des critères
techniques en fait non pas du tout
humain uniquement on se connaît tous ah
oui vous avez fait les mêmes écoles vous
êtes dans les vecteurs
merci
pour lui mettre
malheureusement pour lui je la prendrais
plus tard c'est un autre pilote qui sera
retenu
pour les avions aussi c'est le break
soumis eux aussi à rue des preuves à
chaque vol ils sont auscultés de très
près
[Musique]
au total une quarantaine de personnes
entretiennent les avions en permanence
je retrouve romain ce mécano s'occupe
aussi des fumigènes qui sont l'Alphajet
ont pris la place des missiles
en fait on voit bien les distinctement
les deux cubes ah oui on voit les bidons
on le met et on l'arrête et
instantanément ça alors ça
en fait c'est un électro robinet qui va
ouvrir ou fermer le circuit et c'est le
pilote qui le commande en cabine via son
manche il y a une détente le ce qu'on
appelle le bouton BRM donc bombe Rocket
missiles et en temps normal et utiliser
pour tirer des missiles d'accord et des
bombes là il sera utilisé pour actionner
le fumigène donc c'est à dire ouvrir le
circuit ou le fermer ok c'est un peu la
clé du chaud quand même c'est il y a pas
de couleur de France sur les fumigènes
c'est un peu c'est un peu différent
d'accord et ça ressemble à quoi ça alors
le fumigène c'est c'est de l'huile
colorée en fait de l'huile oui c'est de
l'huile colorée
la couleur et le et pour le blanc c'est
de l'huile de l'huile moteur de huile
minérale classique d'accord voilà on
voit la tête que ça on va voir c'est
fumer bleu blanc rouge font la célébrité
de la patrouille
c'est par ces tuyaux qui sortent près de
l'un des réacteurs que les fumées de
couleur sont pulvérisées
quand ils lâche les fumées le pilote ne
peut donc plus utiliser que l'autre
réacteur pour déclencher ses manœuvres
cette fois l'entraînement sera
particulière car deux des avions sont en
maintenant et l'un des pilotes est
malade le leader en profite pour faire
voler les trois nouveaux
le capitaine blancailleur fait partie
des pilotes restés au sol et assiste
avec nous à l'enchaînement des figures
au-dessus de la base
[Musique]
vous êtes là vous
êtes où dans ces cas-là
exactement d'accord
généralement le public aime beaucoup ça
donc le cœur là c'est le top du top en
public
ouais c'est c'est une figure assez
emblématique au sein de la patrouille
donc
à quoi on pense en fait comme ça
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans la tête là
on est très concentré sur la voie du
leader ça c'est vraiment essentiel et
c'est justement c'est paradoxal mais il
faudrait ne pas penser
c'est
notre grand inquiétude ça va être de
rester dans le moment présent pour ni
penser au passé aux éventuelles erreurs
qui pourraient polluer notre réflexion
et polluer ce qui va se passer après
ni à l'avenir c'est de se dire avant le
reste une super une super démo et que
finalement c'est là que la concentration
va se perdre pas penser à sa femme ni à
ses enfants
quotidienne d'ici on s'est engueulé le
matin et tout ça quoi alors mais tout
est fait pour
à partir du briefing
toute la musique et il y a pas de temps
pour ça en fait il y a vraiment pas de
temps l'implication mentale d'une
mission à la PAF elle est c'est vraiment
du 100% tout le temps
en cas de guerre bien sûr les pilotes de
la Patrouille de France peuvent à
n'importe quel moment abandonner leur
rôle d'acrobate pour rejoindre le
cockpit d'un mirage ou d'un Rafale
vous avez fait la guerre vous la vraie
un petit peu à armenton en Libye en
Libye donc vous avez lâché des bons non
alors moi j'étais j'étais sur Mirage de
métier S1 qui ont osé de la surveillance
du ciel est-ce que le stress la
concentration tout ça ce sont les mêmes
où ils sont différents un poil peut-être
plus joyeux et léger pendant quand on
est là
plus grave quand on fait la guerre
c'est vraiment important à bien
comprendre l'implication mentale et
physique qui est mise dans une mission
de la Patrouille de France elle est la
même que sur la mission guerre cet
après-midi seul un avion volera le mien
ou plutôt celui qui m'emmènera dans le
ciel de Provence
il me reste à accomplir avec Romain une
formalité d'importance me former à
l'utilisation du siège éjectable une
machine qui peut me sauver la vie mais
qui peut aussi me tuer si je m'en sers
mal le fauteuil il part comment
est fixé sur le canon d'éjection canon
d'éjection c'est cette partie là
d'accord ça c'est fixé dans l'avion et
en fait le siège est enquillé dans les
rails d'accord tout le long et au moment
où la séquence direction va commencer le
canon d'éjection lui va se déployer en a
au siège hors de la cabine verticalement
et les moteurs fusils qui se trouvent
sous le ciel pour vous propulser hors de
la trajectoire de l'avion à quelle
distance vous allez partir de pas 80
mètres 80 mètres au-dessus de la viande
et à quel vitesse ça se passe vous allez
partir à une force entre 16 et 19 g
19 fois le poids de mon corps
entre 16 et 19 donc 19 fois 75 kg une
tonne 425
qui est-ce qui décide
d'éjecter au delà de lui-même ou c'est
le pilote il sera dans le salon qui vous
donnera l'ordre de vous éjecter mais
l'action c'est moi mais l'action c'est
vous il va falloir vous installer sur le
siège
je serai assis sur une petite bombe ça
n'est pas très rassurant j'ai croisé il
y a quelques jours le dernier pilote à
cette éjectée à la PAF en 2010 il s'en
est bien remis mais le problème c'est
que moi je n'ai rien dans l'athlète la
poignée d'éjection elle c'est cette
poignée voilà jaune et noire qui est ici
d'accord donc là les sécuriser grâce à
cette épingle à partir du moment où
l'épingle se relever elle sera active la
main la plus forte sur la poignée
d'éjection donc ici l'autre main qui
tient le poignet
on rentre les coudes on ne regarde
surtout pas la poignée pour éviter de se
faire mal aux cervicales
et on tire la poignée
d'accord et je me jette avant le pilote
avant le pilote ok chaque siège
trajectoire différente par un moteur
fusée ont une cuillère inclinée de
manière à pas vous vous percuter en
l'air et vous sortir ce ballon oui je
sais
[Musique]
bon c'est pas super confortable
c'est un peu plus confortable
h -2 direction le Metz avec les mécanos
je n'ignore pas qu'à un avion à réaction
peut vous retourner l'estomac alors
est-ce qu'il faut manger ou pas
et voilà bon appétit bonne journée
c'est mieux
mais pas trop
les mécanos sont sympas et ils veulent
me rassurer mais moi je ne les trouve
pas du tout rassurants
qui puisse soit calmer si peu ou
profiter de ce qui fait
vraiment pas rassurant
on respire plus dans le masque
qui se passe il va parler mais forcément
on n'est pas du tout puisque vous aurez
plus rien c'est bien de venir avant de
dire voilà ça va pas bien je dégrade
[Musique]
à une heure du décollage on équipe
combinaison antigènes
gants
bonnet casque visière masque à oxygène
et bien sûr le fameux sac à vomi
on rit pour donner le change
en allant vers l'avion l'excitation me
gagne marcher vers un Alpha Jet casque à
la main ça fait un peu kéké mais c'est
déjà une sensation forte
comme prévu romain mon mécano est déjà
sur place
[Musique]
j'attendais ce moment depuis le début le
colonel Ambert le directeur de la PAF
ancien leader va me faire un beau cadeau
et j'ai conscience du privilège
[Musique]
un petit cérémonial de sortie
mon prénom c'est Arnaud si jamais
[Applaudissements]
et bien on a tout merci Arnaud d'avance
avec plaisir ça va être très bien
au décodage les sensations sont proches
de celles d'un avion de ligne avec la
vision en plus et l'appréhension et
l'excitation
[Musique]
du sol
on est vraiment tout prêt quoi c'est ça
qui est génial
la première partie du vol est un bonheur
intégral le décor est magnifique les
sensations indescriptibles ça ne
ressemble à rien de ce que je
connaissais
[Musique]
là on est à 200 m
et on va faire demi-tour on va remonter
au frais dans les montagnes
tout va bien impeccable
quand l'avion se met sur une aile je
prends des charges des g c'est une
sensation inconnue
d'entrée j'ai pris 4 G 4 fois le poids
de mon corps 300 kg
ça me plaît c'est nouveau c'est inconnu
c'est agréable
[Musique]
mais très vite viens l'envers de ce
plaisir nouveau la salive qui prend un
drôle de goût la nausée qui vient ternir
le bonheur la peur de vomir dans le
masque de s'étouffer de devoir enlever
le masque et d'en mettre partout la peur
du bonheur gâché
[Musique]
il est temps de sortir le fameux sac
venu des entrailles du pilote amateur
c'est là qu'on réalise à quel point les
pilotes de la PAF sont des
[Musique]
on regarde la ligne droite
victoire je n'ai pas vomi et je vais
pouvoir tranquillement
profiter de la fin du voyage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on rentre
[Musique]
au moment d'atterrir
les nausées sont déjà loin il ne reste
que ce sentiment de liberté de puissance
ce sentiment d'avoir vécu des sensations
uniques
je peux désormais fièrement afficher une
heure de vol à mon palmarès
[Musique]
avant de partir je voudrais mettre les
choses au point j'ai volé sur un
Alphajet de la Patrouille de France
mais pas plus c'est un voyage d'agrément
c'était magnifique on a volé à plat on
allait un peu sur l'aile j'avais très
très mal à l'estomac j'ai failli vomir
voilà j'avais pas envie non plus de
souffrir mais je n'ai pas volé avec la
Patrouille de France je pense pas que ce
soit la portée d'un d'un être humain
normalement constitué pas du tout
préparé que de voler avec la Patrouille
de France ce que font ces petits plats
et très très très très loin de ce que
j'ai pu vivre moi dans cet avion ils
sont
ethniquement à un niveau qui ne me
permet pas de les approcher j'ai envie
de le dire parce que j'ai bien de potes
qui se font un peu mousser en disant
j'ai volé avec la Patrouille de France
tu parles allez bye
[Musique]
il est temps pour moi de repartir à la
découverte de nouveaux horizons ou
m'attendent d'autres hommes d'autres
femmes au métier exceptionnels
[Musique]